[Musik]
nirgendwo sonst in afrika mit so viel
kupfer produziert wie in sofia
kofler ist der name einer stadt in
sambia move lehrer bedeutet ort des
reichtums
über eine briefkastenfirma in der
karibik besitz glencore 75 prozent der
anteile an der kupferhütte und der
schweizer rohstoffkonzern ist der
betreiber der mopay nico familie
[Musik]
filmaufnahmen auf dem betriebsgelände
gestattet lenko nicht und außerhalb
schreite die betriebs polizei von opa
nie ein verlangt abstand
die schwarze schlacke aus dem
schmelzofen ein giftiger abfall frisch
eingezäunt
kinder und arbeitslose aus der
nachbarschaft gruben hierfür nach ein
paar metallreste nun wird die halde
bewacht kalaschnikow griffbereit
glencore will die metallreste selber
zurückgewinnen und verteidigt die
schlacke gegenliebe einer wurde bereits
erschossen
am sonntag tragen die menschen immer
wieder ihre besten kleider
tief unter ihren füßen wird der boden
ein reiches kupfer vorkommen dass
glencore im untertagebau ausbeutet
ein viertel bevölkerung von nokia 30.000
menschen leben im minen quartier bei der
kupferhütte die alte arbeit der siedlung
ist das armenhaus der stadt mit
kriminalität aids arbeitslosigkeit cook
in der arbeit
manche eltern können sich nicht einmal
das geld für die schulgebühren leisten
die häuser sind alt einige drohen
einzustürzen kaum repariert grafen
wieder risse
wenn die da drüben steine aus dem
untergrund verladen dann wackelt das
ganze haus
die arbeitsgeräusche vom schacht nebenan
sind im haus training gut zu hören
wir haben versucht das mit zement zu
füllen er kommt aber wieder raus weil es
immer so wackelt jeden tag
die abschrift eines briefes an die
mopani mine eine bitte um hilfe bei den
reparaturarbeiten
was war die antwort auf den brief
nichts
keine antwort nur schweigen
nebst den mauerresten ist im quartier
das problem mit den dächern besonders
störend wellblech wird hier rasch vom
rost zerfressen
das liegt an den abgasen der kupferhütte
als die noch dem staat gehört wurden die
dächer gratis repariert das ist vorbei
das quartier liegt in der
hauptwindrichtung der fabrik
jetzt wo sich die regenzeit dem ende
zuneigt trägt die feuchte luft einen
beißenden gestank durchs quartier
das ist die zeit in der das feld was da
herunter kommt ist voller säure
der boden ist betroffen die pflanzen
sind betroffen alles betroffen weil der
regen das schwefeldioxid herunter bringt
schwefeldioxid so2 ist giftig und ätzend
reizt augen atemwege kann asthma
verursachen
so2 entsteht in großen mengen wenn
schwefelhaltige kupfererz eingeschmolzen
wird
gemäss einer schätzung der weltbank
bläst klein kurs kupferhütte jährlich
140.000 tonnen schwefeldioxid in die
umwelt das ist zehnmal so viel wie die
gesamte schweiz im jahr ausstößt
markant und zug hauptsitz eines der
mächtigsten unternehmen der welt
interviews gibt bleibt chor keine
informationen nur per telefon
die mopani mine werde saniert heißt es
schon übernächstes jahr gebe es keine
so2 emissionen mehr europa nie habe man
2001 übernommen dass glencore rostende
dächer verantwortlich sei bezweifle mann
und die häuser würden zerfallen weil sie
alt sein
in spittal formulierer zahlreiche
patienten kaum ärzte und medikamente die
vergangene nacht brachte wieder sauren
regen über die stadt
die kinderabteilung
14 fälle kamen heute auf der akkus
station sind noch zwei
dem mädchen geht es schon etwas besser
die mutter die ihr baby im arm trägt
wohnt in minen quartier
[Musik]
konnte das kind kaum mehr atmen
es war sehr schlimm seine temperatur ist
immer noch hoch
sie kamen notfallmässig er ja es war ein
notfall
[Musik]
ich denke sie müssen eine lösung finden
einen anderen ort es ist nicht gut für
unsere gesundheit
der medizinische direktor des spitals
hat über die vergangenen jahre
festgestellt dass zwischen fabrik
abgasen und atemwegserkrankungen ein
zusammenhang besteht
es kommen immer mehr leute mit
lungeninfektionen die die asthma haben
und in dieser gegend leben bei denen
wird asthma schlimmer wenn abgas in der
luft sind
und dann sehen wir auch neugeborene und
kinder unter fünf jahren mit postkorb
infektionen und atemnot
wir stellen da eine verbindung her weil
dann wenn die emissionen hoch sind
patienten kommen die solche beschwerden
haben
das spital erhält keine unterstützung
von glencore zmo pany miene
zurück in bar oder börsengang
vergangenes jahr eine reihe von glencore
managern zu multi milliardären gemacht
hat
ein konzern-sprecher teilt mit in den
akten ihres minen eigenen spitals in mir
finde sich kein einziger fall einer
erkrankung durch luftverschmutzung
lusaka sambia us-hauptstadt als der
staat die mopani cook familie an
glencore verkaufte lag der kupferpreis
unter 2000 dollar pro tonne heute
beträgt er mehr als 8000 dollar
beim direktor der nationalen
umweltbehörde sambias was unternimmt
sein amt um die menschen in la vor den
abgasen der kupferproduktion zu schützen
bei der übernahme von mopani nach der
privatisierung
vereinbarte man dass sie das
schwefeldioxid reduzieren das haben sie
getan mit einer säure fabrik die so2
abgase in schwefelsäure umwandeln wenn
du zwei teure fabrik entsteht ende 2013
sollte das problem behoben sein es ist
schon jetzt viel besser
400 kilometer von der hauptstadt
entfernt riestern akasol arbeitet als
sozialberaterin imove lehrer vergangenes
jahr hatte sie in lusaka beim parlament
vorgesprochen wegen des schwefeldioxid
sie wartet noch immer auf eine antwort
der politiker
so wie sich das säure problem im
vergleich zu früheren jahren entwickelt
hat ist es jetzt schlimmer
darum gibt es hier fälle von
lungenentzündung von tape von asthma und
es zerstört unsere häuser
lancool sagt sie hätten das
schwefeldioxid um die hälfte reduziert
das ist eine glatte lüge
gibt es weniger abgase als früher nein
im gegenteil
in zahlreichen familien die unter den
löchrigen dächern der siedlung leben
treten jungen krankheiten auf
nur ein beispiel beim haus des minen
angestellten amerika tb er arbeitet
unter tage als fahrer
sein sohn freeman benötigt asthmamittel
als mobile die anlagen gebaut hat
dachten wir die abgase würden reduziert
in schwebe zu säure wandeln aber bis
heute hat sich nichts verändert
[Musik]
ich bin froh dass meine kinder im
million spital von mopani umsonst
medikamente erhalten ich kann sie ins
minen spital bringen leider ist es für
die die nicht bei uns angestellt sind
oder arbeitslos schwierig medizinische
betreuung zu erhalten
fürchten sie dass sie ihren job
verlieren könnten wenn sie sich beklagen
wenn ich reklamiere gebe ich doch der
firma die möglichkeit etwas zu tun und
wenigstens das schwefeldioxid zu
reduzieren
ist move lehrer in industriestandort wie
viele andere übertreiben die betroffenen
gar was meint der chefarzt
ich war acht jahre in russland
zweieinhalb in deutschland ich war in
japan und den usa der umweltschutz dort
ist ausgezeichnet ich denke nicht dass
so etwas irgendwo in europa akzeptiert
wurde
wenn etwas gut für europa ist weshalb
ist es dann nicht auch gut für afrika
[Musik]
glencore veröffentlich keine messdaten
zur luftbelastung aber die weltbank hat
zahlen publiziert vergangenes jahr im
kleingedruckten eines umweltberichts der
schwefeldioxid grenzwert der
weltgesundheitsorganisation ist
überschritten bei der einen messstelle
um 100 bei der anderen um 83 prozent
glencore sagt die angaben würden auf
beschränktem datenmaterial beruhen
1,2 milliarden dollar hat glencore
tochtergesellschaft in sambia voriges
jahr umgesetzt bei 200 millionen
ausgewiesenen gewinn
in sachen so2 heißt es eine raschere
vollständige sanierung sei nicht möglich
man müsse die produktion
aufrechterhalten um massenentlassungen
zu verhindern
über diese pipelines entsorgt die mopani
mine ihre prozess abfälle schlamm der
nebst sand auch giftige chemikalien und
schwermetalle enthält
mehrere millionen tonnen des schlamms
fließen jährlich durch die alten röhren
manchmal liegt eine
am ende der pipeline
in einem bericht von 2011 von glencore
in auftrag gegeben und beim börsengang
publik geworden heißt es die
schadstoffwerte überschreiten zum teilen
das behördliche limit
der überlauf der deponie ergießt sich
weiter unten in den fluss kaffee haben
wir das wasserreservoir glencore teilt
mit das wasser aus der deponie werde
überwacht es sei unbedenklich
diese grünen bohnen im armen quartier
hat glencore gespendet 28 davon
es ist eines der freiwilligen
sozialprojekte des konzerns dazu gehören
auch zwei schulen und in der nähe des
stadtzentrums von nofilia das minen
spital
hier ist das filmen erlaubt das spital
ist ein beleg für glencore soziales
unternehmertum das krankenhaus ist iso
zertifiziert
die angestellten von mopani werden bei
unfall und krankheit unentgeltlich
behandelt das spital ist auch öffentlich
zugänglich gegen geringe gebühr heißt es
verkehrsopfer erhalten erste hilfe
umsonst
auf der kinderabteilung
von den betten die zur verfügung stehen
sind wenige besetzt
der chefarzt und der sicherheitschef der
mine ein interview gibt es nicht nur
eine rasche frage was gehört zur
unternehmerischen sozialverantwortung
unbedingt das ist die unternehmerische
sozialverantwortung von mo panik wir
leben in einer gemeinde da können wir
uns nicht von den realitäten abkoppeln
zurück im staatlichen spital ist die
glencore klinik ein vorzeigeobjekt
ja sie ist jetzt für die öffentlichkeit
zugänglich aber die gebühren sind sehr
hoch eine zulassung kostet umgerechnet
etwa 850 dollar
in einem solchen land dieser gemeinde
wer kann sich das schon leisten
das ist praktisch unmöglich browser mal
ist sehr reich aber wie viele von uns
sind schon reich
auch hier im öffentlichen spital werden
minenarbeiter behandelt die arbeiter
zweiter klasse die für vertragsfirmen
von mopani arbeiten ihre
behandlungskosten prägte start
für glenn kurs mine in not ihrer
arbeiten gegenwärtig 8500 menschen aber
nur etwa die hälfte von ihnen ist direkt
beim opa nie angestellt der mindestlohn
beträgt 500 dollar im monat das sei
überdurchschnittlich
die andere hälfte der arbeiter die für
vertragsfirmen arbeitet erhält einen
bruchteil dieses lohnes
der neue schmelzofen von 2006 verfügt
über eine säure fabrik sie verwandelt
einen teil der eso zwei abgase in
schwefelsäure
weil der neue ofen viel mehr kupfer
schmilzt hat die abgas menge nicht
abgenommen aber glencore produziert nun
schwefelsäure zusätzlich die braucht es
ohnehin um kupferkonzentrat herzustellen
mopani musste die säure zuvor teuer
importieren
die schwefelsäure wird in der raffinerie
eingesetzt und lenker benutzt sie auch
für ganz neue methoden der
kupfergewinnung
die abgase steigen derweil weiter in den
himmel
[Musik]
eine schlaglochpiste im westen von
muffler
am rande dieses quartiers steht klein
kurs neuestes projekt
gleich hinter diesen häusern lässt der
konzern die schwefelsäure versprühen die
aus den fabrik abgasen gewonnen wird die
anwohnerinnen sind empört
dort sehen sie den haufen für die ehrung
und da drüben die säure becken sogar der
vizepräsident stand da drüben wir
sprachen mit ihm aber es wurde nichts
dagegen unternommen
wir wissen möchten wir es tun
ein übler geruch liegt in der luft
glencore hat einen riesigen hügel aus
kupfererz aufgeschichtet
drüben ist schutzkleidung vorgeschrieben
tausende kubikmeter schwefelsäure werden
jährlich per leitung auf den haufen
gespült die säure sicher durchs herz
löst das kupfer sammelt sich in den
schwarzen offenen becken die flüssigkeit
wird schließlich zu kupfer weiter
verarbeitet
mit diesem konzept kann kupfer besonders
kostengünstig hergestellt werden doch
die umweltbehörde sambias hat die anlage
im märz einstweilen stillgelegt trotz
zahlreicher einsprachen von glencore
gibt er direktor bei herrlich
es gab viele beschwerden von anwohnern
gingen hin verifizierten sprachen mit
der gemeinde und stellten fest dass die
beschwerden begründet waren
dann gegen wirklichen mopani vor allison
einen schutz befehl und verlangten
verbesserungen damit die anlage die
menschen nicht weiter schädel
bei hoher luftfeuchtigkeit verbreitet
die anlage immer noch sauer nebel
das sind medikamente die wir
aufgebraucht habe mit der gegen husten
durchfall augentropfen das haben wir
alles mit unserem eigenen geld bezahlt
seine zähne verfahren wir mussten ihm in
der klinik einige ziehen lassen
wegen des geruchs vermuten die mütter
die anlage sei weiter in betrieb
die heutige anlage noch
nein die ist eingestellt
der lügt doch man kann es ja richtig
aber wir wissen gar nicht mehr
er hat angst seinen job zu verlieren er
arbeitet für mopani
der wächter fordert verstärkung an der
betrieb schutz von mopani kommt im
geländewagen
was ihr am prenzlauer berg
die sicherheitsleute versuchen die
mieter einzuschüchtern erfolglos
sie bedrohen uns weil wir ihnen erlaubt
haben hierher zu kommen
die bedrohten sie ja sie sagten wir
sollen den mund halten
[Musik]
die vorwürfe betreffend
gesundheitsschäden durch schwefelsäure
sei nicht fundiert teilt glencore aus
baar später mit
das kommt von der säure in der fabrik
das ist mein haus
chris pilati arbeitet in der raffinerie
und lebt mit seiner familie gleich neben
dem großen haufen
die kinder haben schwierigkeiten beim
atmen
das hört nicht auf wir haben
verschiedene probleme nur wegen der
säulen unsere zähne verorten schauen sie
meine zähne an
die säure wird gleich da drüben
versprüht der haufen steht viel zu nah
an unserem haus
das ist mein zweiter sohn
wenige wochen nach diesen aufnahmen
durfte mopani die anlage wieder in
betrieb nehmen man habe die
prozessabläufe weiter optimiert sagt
glencore
nein
glencore verteidigt sein territorium
auch in bar
auf der chefetage schmiedet man
fusionspläne
glencore sei ein wichtiger investor und
arbeitgeber in entwicklungsländern teilt
der konzern mit nachhaltiges handeln sei
seine maxime
der kupferpreis ist in den letzten
jahren nach oben geschnellt mopani hat
die produktion auf über 200.000 tonnen
gesteigert und glencore investiert
weiter in den kupferabbau
[Musik]
in dem ort des reichtums ist vom profit
wenig zu sehen
das schafft im boden ist für die meisten
menschen kein segen
[Musik]
ja ja